[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar how to streamline your variant
classification workflow with hgmd
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by kyogen
to learn more visit kyogen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
iriselli cuellar phd senior field
application scientist at kiochen digital
insights
arisely you may now begin your
presentation
so thank you for the introduction and
thank you for being here today today
we'll talk about how hdmd can help
streamline your variant classification
workflow
and so today we'll start with the
introduction to the human gene mutation
database and look at some of the
advantages of htmd professional
i will then look at some examples of use
cases that many varying scientists like
you often encounter but illustrate how
hcmd is a valuable tool to help you with
your barrier research i will then end
with a q a session
so what is the human gene mutation
database it is an expert curated
database of human german mutations
coming from peer-reviewed published
journals
these are both denoble and inherited
mutations that have significant evidence
of pathogenicity
and so here on the right-hand side you
can see a venn diagram comparing the
content between
htmt omen and a klimbar
you can see that all of the content from
omen is in htmd
and nearly 55 of the clinvar entries are
also found within hdmt
now i would like to say that if it's not
published it's not an hmd so keeping
this in mind uh this remaining 73 000 of
claim our entries are likely not in htmd
because clinvar does not necessarily
require users
who are submitting their clinical
adaptations about a variance you have
specific guidelines for evidence to
support that assertion
now you can also see that um
hcmd has a large amount of content that
is not available in either omen or
clinvar
now one thing to note is that hmd is for
german mutations only
not for somatic so hmd is a great tool
when you're asking the question does
this human germline mutation cause
disease
now many of you are probably aware that
there is a public version of h
gmd
and so here let's take a look at the
advantages of having a professional
version
i like the public version which is three
years out of date
htmt professional is updated quarterly
with information coming from more than
2000 different journals
and is carried out manually by genetic
experts
who read the literature and bring in the
information
and so here on the right you can see the
statistics between this year
and the fourth quarter release of 2021
for hcmd
and you can see that there is quite a
bit of content that was just added
between these two quarters
uh currently
htmd includes annotations for more than
362 000 variants
all kinds of mutations represent a
growth of about 9 500 mutations within
one quarter
so you can see that
having the professional version compared
to the public version
um
gives you the most up-to-date clinical
information for these variants
now hdmt entries include the first
published example of the mutation
and the pathogenic effect
and certain mutations may also include
additional reports like functional
studies or additional phenotypes
if these reports enhance the original
entry
and so there are a couple of ways that
you can access this information
hcmd can be accessed online
and with aged with the hdmd professional
version you have advanced search
capabilities that are not necessarily
available with the public version
so as you can see here
you have the ability to search by gene
or mutation
you can do phenotype searches
and you can also
look at an overview of
limitations for a specific gene
to get an idea of the number of
mutations by varying type
in addition to the online version
a downloadable
version of hmd professional is also
available
so you prefer to have the data in tab
dna
files or vcf files that's also available
now we're going to look at some examples
that illustrate how hdmd is a
particularly useful tool during your
variant classification workflow
specifically we'll look at how
convenient hemd is when researching a
variant's clinical significance
ways in which visualizing variants
through hdmd can provide information
about the allele of interest that you're
looking at
and then we'll also look at ways to
identify genes associated with specific
phenotypes
and then how you can utilize some of the
advanced abilities to design an ngs
panel
now when it comes to
interpreting variants
legacy and alternative naming schemes
can make researching a variant's
clinical significance kind of difficult
so let's say that you're given
this variant
in gene subpoena a subpoena one
to look over
now a workflow for this might be the
following
using the human genome variation society
hgbs monoclature
for this variant
the first thing you do is go to clinvar
but because you don't necessarily want
to take the entries in quinblar at face
value you dig a little deeper into the
entry
and see the literature
associated for that variant
uh looking at the clinvar entry for this
um serine look at codon six leucine
change
there's no mention of an alternative
names or other schemes
so using this literature information
that's associated with the clinvar entry
you go to pubmed to investigate it
further
and so looking at the associated paper
um the only serine to leucine change
mentioned is happening at codon minus
19.
in addition to this you notice that
this is somewhat also associated with
something called piz
rexam
so at this point you are not seeing any
mention
of a serine
6 leucine
so the next thing you do is go to the
gene review
for subpoena one where you confirm that
alpha one anti-trypsin deficiency is the
associated phenotype
and you get a little bit of background
information about this gene
you see that variants were initially
described based on electrophoretic
protein variants with the prefix
pi
denoting protease inhibitor so
essentially they would add this pi in
conjunction with the name of the
location where this variant was
identified
and all of this was before they knew
that subpoena one was the associated
gene
so here not only do you have what
appears to be
a legacy name
where the codon is different but you
also have this
alternative meaning
scheme based on the location of where
the variant was found
however at this point
uh you're still not quite sure
that you can confirm that
serine 6 leucine
is in fact the same variant as serine
minus 19 that lucy
and so um you look at the omen entry and
you get some similar information
the same literature is associated
uh the same names are given
nonetheless you still don't have any
confirmation that um this
is the same variant you're looking for
and so at this point you suspect that it
is but to be certain
you would have to do uh additional
digging to confirm that the information
you are finding is relevant to the
variant you're interested in
so overall you can see how
time-consuming this workflow can be
now let's look at how using hcmd as your
first step in your variant
classification workflow provides you
with that background information and
saves you the time spent worship
researching these legacy and alternative
naming schemes
and so with htmd
you can search for gene
subpoena
one
and look at this sense of variance
and so here within the first entry
you see the variant you're interested in
steering six smoothing and conveniently
hcmd has a special column
that describes the legacy change so here
you can see
that there is an offset of 24 amino
acids explaining why you are seeing this
minus a 19.
this is probably part of a translocation
signal or something and the original
group studying this variant started
counting 24 codons downstream
and so you have confirmation
that
serine 6 leucine
is in fact the same variant as serine
minus 19 lucy
you can click on this
hdmd assertion
to view the variant entry
and so in this
variant entry you get confirmation that
the associated disease or phenotype is
alpha 1 antitrypsin deficiency
hdmd considers this variant a
disease-causing mutation
and then again you have the codon number
and the legacy codon number is also
available in this view
you also have
the primary literature reference for the
first time this variant was published as
well as an additional reference
and so at this point you can be
confident that when you are talking
about this
serine six leucine
it's the same thing mentioned in this
primary literature
and this is because the genetic experts
who are reviewing the information and
updating the content within htmd will
not associate literature
if there is any ambiguity
they will follow up with the authors of
the publication
if there are any questions
so they have done the background digging
for you
saving you time so you can move forward
with your research
now let's look at another use case let's
say that you are given uh this variant
in gene uh gna
so here you're looking at a arginine
297
glutamine change so let's go ahead and
search this in hgmt
and so when you log in to
hcmd professional online this is what
the home page looks like
here you have the current version
you have a list of the contents that are
available and any important
announcements or updates will also be
listed
now there are a number of ways to search
you can search itunes
so here we click on gene
we'll get the option to search by gene
so here we can enter our gene of
interest
and then use this drop down menu to
select
the parameter that we're interested in
and then submit the query
once you do that we can simply select
our gene
and so with a gene search
you can look at all the mutations
within gene
e
and then you can narrow it down by
imitation type of interest so if you're
interested in this sense mutations
you can click on that
and then
scroll down until you find the one that
you're interested in
now another way is to search by mutation
which directly pulls up the varying
information so here you click on
mutation
uh you can search by codon
if you have the hgmd a session
you can directly look it up
uh you can search also by dbsnp as well
now for today we are going to search by
chromosomal coordinates
and so using this little search bar up
here you can either type in or paste in
your coordinates so i'm going to go
ahead and paste those in
and then use
this drop down menu to specify how we
are searching
so we're going to search by
hg38 coordinates
and then click on submit
and so this directly
pulls up the variant you are interested
in
here you can click on the gene symbol
and get the same spectrum of mutations
that you get when you search by the gene
function
you also have the option to link out to
db snip
and you can also review the htmt
assession for this variant so let's go
ahead and do that
and so looking at this assession uh you
can see that the associated phenotype is
sileria
the hmd entry is citing this as a
disease causing mutation
and then
you don't see anything in the codon
number about a legacy naming scheme
here in the literature
citation section
uh you can see that there are a couple
of different papers listed
uh the for the first report was in a
portuguese girl who had the clinical
biochemical and molecular
characteristics
and in addition to the primary
literature
these papers are also included because
the reviewers found that these papers
added useful information
now something that users like you find
particularly helpful
is this comments and notes section
and so here reviewers will add notes to
help clarify things
so as an example we are looking at a 297
code on change
but within this leroy paper
it indicates that it's a 266 code on
change
and then looking at the note for another
publication of the reviewers lets you
know that this paper also reports it the
same way
and gives the ensemble transcript
now another thing that is helpful is
that many times the comments will tell
you where to look for the variant
so if it's only listed in the
supplemental table or the supplemental
data
it will point you in that direction
and so this shows the value of having
someone manually look at the information
not only are they reviewing the body of
the text but they are also able to look
at graphs figures supplemental tables
and they point you to where they found
that key piece of information for the
variant
now with this information you know that
there is a reporting scheme on different
transcripts than the one that you've
been given so hdmd has this section
called additional predicted
hgvs descriptions
feature and so if you click on the
little arrows
you can see the drop down menu appears
and here
it lists all of the rest transcripts the
hgbs transcriptions as well as the
ensemble transcripts
and so this use case highlights how
reviewing the hdmd entry first gives you
key insights that will that will be
helpful as you continue with your
literature review
so if you were to look for additional
literature
for this a specific variant
uh you would know that there is a
possibility that it is reported a number
of different ways so you would need to
be aware when you are doing that search
and how you form that search
so we've looked at how hmd can help you
with your variant research and save you
time along the way
now we'll look at some use cases for
downloading and visualizing hmd data
so when you have a professional license
for hdmd download there are there are
several different files that are
available to you
um here highlighted is the zipped file
for the vcf or hmd professional
in hg 38 but it's also available in hg19
as well
so before moving to the use case i'll
briefly go over how you would go about
uploading this data for visualization
and so here you would download
the vcf file
and then upload the vcf file to a
browser for this many users like you
will either use the integrative genomics
viewer igb or the uc santa cruz genome
browser
and so to give you an idea this is what
the upload of the hemg professional bcf
looks like in igp
if we zoom in on the information here
this is information parsed from the vcf
file you can see the gene
uh the phenotype
the
hgbs non-equature so you can use this to
get the key information
and this is what the upload of the hdmd
professional bcf looks like in the uc
santa cruz genome browser
this allows you to see the nature of the
variant change so you can see if you
have
a deletion
for example
or if you have
an insertion
you can also see if you have a
substitution
as well so it provides you with just a
little bit more
information
and then
this is what the parse information from
the bcs would look like in the
uc santa cruz genome browser
so let's go ahead and see how we can use
the
hgmd vcs download
so many users like you
when they download the hdmd vcf file
will often use it during their secondary
analysis
they will refer to the vcf from hmd and
annotate their variants
so let's say that you did sequencing and
generated a large list of
variants
now you want to narrow down this list to
look at those that are most likely to be
clinically significant
so one of the things that you can do is
filter by things like allele frequency
or quality matrix
with the hgmd vcs download you can also
annotate with
hdmd and use the annotations to filter
down to a smaller list of variants to
look at in more details
now another use case for the h gmd vcs
download is for visualization purposes
so why is visualization helpful
sometimes you want to see what's in what
we call the genomic neighborhood
this can be visualizing a bcf track for
your variants of interest and by using
the vcf download you're able to see if
there are entries within hmg that are at
the same codon and see if they are
marked as disease-causing mutations or
supposed to use cause mutations
and so
for example
i have uploaded
these
variant tracts
of
my bearing of interest and the
hemg vcs into the uc
santa cruz genome browser
and so here we go to the genome
you can see
both the
the
hdmd vcf file and then
the
file for our variant of interest
and so looking at the browser
we have our variant of interest
right here
and then we can see that there are hdmd
entries at the same location
so if we look at these entries
and we click on the information
you can see that um
hmd is citing this as a disease
contention so having this visual
representation is quite helpful for many
users like you
now other times you may find
visualization helpful if you are looking
at a particular region of the gene
so for example if you are looking at
friendships at the pre-prime end and you
have something that's past the boundary
of nonsense media decay you need
additional evidence from the literature
or from functional studies showing that
that last part of the protein has
significance that is cut off
so being able to see visually an hmd
track showing other reported disease
cost mutations in that location will
point you to some of that evidence
now having the hdmd track loaded can
help confirm your secondary analysis
and make sure that is accurately
calling or describing variants
and so let's say that you uploaded your
variant track
into the uc santa cruz geno browser
your variant of interest here in purple
is within the apc gene
and it's in a region where
there is a little bit of repetition with
this agag motif
you can see that there is a little dash
on top followed by a ga
on the bottom indicating that this is an
insertion of a ga
now by loading the hdmd track on top
which is
what all of these variants on the top
are
you can see that there is an insertion
of a ga
in blue that's nearby or in the genomic
neighborhood
as a person reviewing this variant and
maybe examining the bed or bam files or
the breeds
you might suspect that this insertion
is in fact supposed to be called here
a few bases away downstream because
repetitive regions sometimes there can
be changes in how it is represented in
the bcf versus hgvs
in this case uh you would know to follow
up maybe with finger sequencing for
confirmation to make sure that
this
is in fact the variant you want to look
at and that it doesn't need to be
altered
in your secondary analysis
to reflect something that has been
reported in the literature as a disease
causing mutation
and so overall you can see how having
this visualization makes this type of
analysis faster
now that we have looked at some of the
applications for using the hdmd ecf
download
let's look at how you can utilize hdmd
when you are interested in identifying
genes that associate with a specific
phenotype of interest
for example
let's say that you are on the research
side and you are interested in
discovering what genes are associated
with bipolar disorder
with hcmd you can search
by phenotype
and so here you can do a
boolean
search where it will pull in the actual
entries with the term bipolar
disorder
and search within hcmd phenotypes
so you can quickly find
for the associated bipolar disorder
phenotypes within hcmd
a list of genes to follow up on
now
this is going to provide um a good place
to start as this provides
some guidance into where
to
look
at now let's look at how you can utilize
the content within hmd to define a count
based on a phenotype
now let's say that you want to assign a
panel for cardiomyopathy
so
in this case you would use the advanced
search
and so with that uh you would get a list
of variants
within hdmd that are associated with
cardiomyopathy
which can then be used for your panel
design
so let's go ahead and do this in the
hemd professional
online version
so here we're going to go ahead and
click on the advanced
section
and then within advanced we're going to
select nucleotide substitution plus
and so today
we are interested in searching
by a disease or phenotype
but uh taking a look at these different
parameters you can see that you can
search by different things such as gene
symbol
uh db snap just to give you a couple of
examples
now you can search by um functional
elements so if you want to look at
variants within known transcription
binding sites for example
this can be helpful
you can do
a motif search
if you're looking for splice specific
splice variants or regulatory regions so
you can also search for those as well
now over here
you can see
what is going to be
produced by the search and so here you
can select the different outputs the
information that you want to receive
back
and so right now we have um many things
highlighted but you can manually select
and deselect
whatever it is that you're interested in
this case i'm just going to go ahead and
select them all
to get as much information as possible
and so going back down here since we are
interested in
searching by a disease or phenotype
we're going to go ahead and use this
search bar to enter
our disease of interest
and so here we are going to specify that
we're interested in
cardiomyopathy
and then we're going to go ahead and
submit our query
and so this pulls the table that you saw
earlier that lists on the different
variants within hdmd
that are associated with cardiomyopathy
and then here each column is going to
represent the outputs that we um
selected so you have information on the
tv snip how the gene
the hgbs
and then you have additional information
as well
and so you can download a bed file
for this table that you can upload into
the uc santa cruz genome browser for
example and so with this you can
visualize across all the associated
genes for cardiomyopathy and known
variants
if you then wanted to design targets for
a panel you can make sure that they are
covering all of these associated hdmd
entries
we also have the option to export
and save this information that's in a
tabular format
by clicking right here to save it as a
text file and then use it for downstream
applications
and so today we looked at the utility of
hemd for varying classification
you saw how it can speed up your
workflow process by giving new
information about historical or legacy
names and different transcripts for
example
so you can quickly get through your
literature search and get to your answer
now you just like you can use the data
within hmd to visualize or
to annotate
and help with other aspects of very
analysis
hmd has many different options for
searching information like my phenotype
for example you can also utilize the
information within hdmd to help design a
panel based on a phenotype like we saw
today
uh thank you for your time and attention
and now we're open for any questions
that you may have
thank you aristeli for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question is how frequently is
hgmd pro updated how does this compare
to the public version
a great question so htmt pro is updated
quarterly whereas the public version is
uh less up to date
um so i believe it's around um
three years um
behind at the um hdmd pro
great thank you another question we have
here asks does hgmd provide information
about polymorphisms in genes
yes for applying margin to be included
in hcmt there must be some sort of
literature evidence showing a link to a
disease or a phenotype
great another question we have here
is there an uploadable vcf with more
information included from the hgmd entry
uh yes with the download of genome
tracks which you can license
you have a number of different files
that are specifically formatted to
for upload into the uc santa cruz juno
browser and there are different ways
that you can view the hdmd entry either
by phenotype disease mutation
functional polymorphism just to give you
a couple of examples
great thank you
next question which genome build is used
for hdmd
so currently hdmd has been updated for
hg38 but there is also support for hg19
as well
great thank you
are there any other ways of accessing
hgmd data other than through hdmd public
or hdmd pro
so hmd data can be accessed through qci
interpret
so with uci interpret you can see the
hemd pro entry for every variant in your
vcf file that goes through
qci interpret and for which there is an
hdmd assession available
great thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question here and
this one asks
why are there articles for a specific
variant that have not been captured in
hgmd but can be found using other search
tools like pubmed
that's a great question so the aim of
hmd is to show the primary report
the first report to where the variant is
published in literature
and additional articles are only added
if there's something new or important to
the entry like an updated phenotype or
functional evidence about protein
structure for example and so here the
goal of hmd is not necessarily to return
all of the possible information
available for the variant but to give
you key background information that is
important
wonderful well thank you again arisely
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor kayajin for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you